hey y'all it's andrew cash here
and this is tuesday video we're going to
be analyzing um this week's data set
which is actually coffee ratings which
comes from i think
um buzzfeed's data scientist
and it also was posted in kaggle
so that's kind of a cool data set um
there's a decent amount of features
and it mainly revolves around the
ratings for each coffee bean
from like each farm so first what we're
going to do is just
load in the data set so we're going to
copy this thing which is copy ratings
go on our studio and open up a
markdown file oops in our markdown file
um
okay and i'm going to call this like
tidy
tuesday coffee
ratings cool
you could span that
okay i'm gonna delete this stuff
and i'm actually using my laptop so i'm
gonna be a little bit slower but
i'm sure they'll be good for everyone in
this case we're just gonna load up the
tidy verse and the copy ratings
so um i was reading comments last week
and i
saw that a lot of you guys wanted to
wanted me to talk about
specifically are shiny and
i actually have done a few are shiny
videos in the past where i just kind of
make some random dashboards however i
think it'd be
a good idea to really go on and explain
the main ideas behind
our shining and i actually prefer shiny
dashboard over like
the base r shiny so we'll probably make
a dashboard
for this this coffee stuff additionally
i think
um i want to kind of show you how to do
like a workflow
um to actually create these dashboards
um for me since i have two monitors and
that's my
daily driver it's very easy for me to
make dashboards where i basically will
have
like a a markdown file on one monitor
and then another monitor i'll just have
my app running
but i'm sure a lot of you guys just have
a laptop or want to do it
while you're on the run so i figured i'd
just make it um
make this dashboard on a laptop and kind
of show you how i would make these like
basic
dashboards that you might want to show
like if you're doing a reporting project
it's easier to give someone a nice
little um
dashboard for them to kind of look at
than it is to show them a basic html or
pdf file
so that's what we're going to be doing
today first what we're going to do is
actually looking at this
data set so i'm just going to do a
glimpse
on it and we can see that there's a lot
of stuff here right
but the main thing that i see is is
first we have a lot of these like random
factors or
this kind of like messy um data
right here with like aroma towards like
uh
what uniformity clean cup sweetness uh
cover points
um i think that's something that we'll
probably be using a lot
in our analysis so one of the other
things we should see is total cut points
so i guess it's like the rating if i go
to uh say
right here and read the data dictionary
it says like total cut points which is
the total
range rating over points available on a
0 to 100 scale
we can see species owner country farm
name
i think when we're making a dashboard it
would be cool to have a
you know if you click on a country and
show like oh who here are all the farms
you know hear like all the types of
beans
so we'll probably play with a lot of
that type of stuff we might also play
with like the method of
the processing method so it could be
like a washed or kind of like a dry
method for it
and we're also going to be using these
aroma grades because i think the big
idea between this copyrighting thing
is saying like oh um if i want like say
a ethiopian cup
how's the acidity grade or how's the
aftertaste or how's the overall
flavor stuff like that so
um we'll definitely look at that um the
bottom end with like
certification uh unit measurements
stuff like that i'm probably not going
to really look at
i'm also going to look at kind of like
the being quality and probably the
origin and stuff like that
so let's start going into it um
additionally i think he also talked
about how
where is it he altitude is a messy
column
so i'm probably gonna ignore that too
but let's look let's start looking at
something
um so if we're really gonna be centered
around like the rating we should always
kind of look at the total
cut points so that's what we'll do
okay so we'll do uh copy ratings
uh ggplot yes uh total
cut points and then do a i don't know a
gm histogram
okay cool so we see that it's definitely
centered around um what is it a 75 and
stuff like that
so it's pretty biased towards one end
um it's not like a normalized rating at
all so maybe if we do a scaling so we'll
say like the scale
x uh log 10.
and then yeah you can see how it's a
little bit more spread out
um that's pretty interesting so most
people are kind of grading pretty highly
this could be because uh it's kind of
like a subset of it let me see if i can
read more about it
um data was cooked for the instant
review pages
coffee cupping okay
so i guess it's also was it fair trade
coffee
so that might be a little bit biased so
this is only fair trade coffee
and fair trade coffee might just be
better than the rest of the like you
know the grocery brand stuff
that kind of makes sense um one thing
that i was thinking about is
when we're looking at it we can see that
there's um like owner
farm name company i'm curious what are
the what are the differences between
that
type of stuff so let's do that so let's
kind of look at these factors so we'll
select
uh was it owner oops
owner
company was and farm name
and then what i'm going to do is
actually a distinct just to see how many
combinations there are
so about 722 different um combinations
of owner
company farm name okay cool
so one thing i think we should do is
let's just
do simple counts so let's just count
owner first those are 316
different owners um i'll do a sword
equals true
sort true and we see i guess
juan who luis our alvarado
romero owns about 155 whether companies
or farms
so we should probably figure out what
what they do so let's just count it
for company
okay
interesting
and then one thing that i'm also
thinking so this owner
wanna lease uh romero
he owns 86 unix guatemalas and i'm sure
the unix funnel miles
has like a certain amount of farms
okay so an owner can own multiple
companies and a company can own multiple
farms
okay so let's let's just make sure that
that makes sense
company farm
com farm or farm
name
maybe do it so there's a decent amount
of n a so i'll just drop those just see
it
yeah so there's there's multiple farms
farms but
you know these companies own say like
okay they own
three like 23 rio verdes 13
fazenda okay cool that makes sense so
i'll say owners
can own multiple companies
companies and comp pennies
can own multiple uh farms
so these farms could also be um
um owned by like multiple companies so
let's let's figure that out
too coffee ratings oops
ratings count fire name
by was it a comp
company
maybe like a sword equals
maybe we'll do a arrange by farm
name
so one thing we also see is there's also
some
data quality where it's like 2000
farmers 2000 farms
i'm not sure if that's the same thing or
not um
okay maybe we'll do a drop in a first
two just to make sure
so delicious farm and stuff like that
okay so we can kind of see how
like yunnan louise herbs r d
center union new country tech they're
kind of the same company
um i was exactly the same company but
they're on different like
there might be subsidiaries of each
other so how about what you should do
owner right farms have
different owners okay maybe we'll go
oops go there
actually and then i can do it i bet i
can do a account
for name sort equals true
yep so so farmers can be owned by
multiple people
or multiple owners okay
okay cool so let's actually start making
some charts
for our dashboard and what i'm going to
do first is let's just
look at uh like a country's
um let's see let's think about how we
can do this you could look at our
country's just like
aromas and flavors i think that's
probably useful thing
so let's do that
so coffee
ratings and i'll do uh
was it select country
of origin and then i want to select all
those
rating things so it's what is it aroma
2 where else is it aroma two
i think it's copper points because i
think that's scale of 10 so let's do
that
copper points
cool
and then actually i'll do uh was it
is it total points and total cut points
and then we'll maybe we'll do a gather
key goals
key value equals value
minus total cup
points minus country
of origin uh
what's going on here
coffee ratings um
oh and i'm i'm actually gonna do another
thing so i'll say mutate
uh row num equals row
number so what i'm basically doing is
i'm validating whether
it's the same thing um
if we're selecting all the good ratings
right and then we could do like a like a
group by row num
there's a row num
and then summarize
we'll say was it a value
equals some value and then we'll say uh
total cut points equals
mean total cut points
okay so yeah that's that's right i also
said mean total cut points just because
i didn't want to drop this
i'm sure there's a way to do it um but i
forgot how to do it um
i want to say it's dot drop equals false
but it's fine
so we know that um
verify that we selected
the correct features
for point analysis cool
so now what we can do is we can go back
select that remove the total cut points
i mean total yeah total cup once and
then what we can start doing is we can
say
let's filter first say country of origin
equals let's say ethiopia
and now let's do a basic gg plot just so
we can see it so we'll do a
gather kegels key
key value equals value minus
country origin
and then it's a simple uh
was it a group by
we'll say country of origin
and key and we could say summarize
value equals and we'll say what we want
to calculate what's the average
profile for each country so we'll say
value equals
mean value
and then we can just ungroup it
so technically um we could just
not select that we could just say uh we
could actually
do this first this this will probably
make it a little bit cleaner so we can
remove that
do that
uh select that stuff
and then we can just throw this into a i
believe i
gather
and instead of counter by order we could
do that so it's a little bit cleaner
then we can do a uh ggplot
you know y equals key x
actually we say uh x equals value
y equals key plus gm like
column right
cool and then we should probably do a
mutate
um key equals factor reorder
we'll do by key in value
and we have a nice little thing honestly
i'm not really liking this chart i think
there's a lot of chart junk just
because um you know they're only um this
for was it ethiopia's clean cup
uniformity and sweetness are the only
thing that are higher
so what i'm actually going to do is i'm
going to switch to x equals key
y equals value switch this to a
a gm point and then do a geom
segment x equals k x
n equals k y equals value
and yn
equals zero so this is what's called a
lollipop chart
and i really love a good lollipop short
chart
i'm also going to do minus value
so it looks a little bit cleaner there's
less width there's less
space that's taken out you know edward
tuff would say it's a little bit more
efficient
size equals five just for a little bit
readability
and then we'll say color equals key
and okay so now we're just going to do
some basic formatting so we'll say like
plus theme legend.position equals none
and then for uh
y lab i'll say like average
full flavor oops flavor profile
um xlab
remove that cool
another thing that i'm probably to do is
adjust the labels a little bit so i'm
going to do
a wizard
mutate key equals let's say
ester replace key and then we're going
to do that
with the underscore with a space
we're also going to do a str was it a
2 title i think that'll do it
cool so aftertaste clean cut copper
points
hmm i have another idea
i'm actually going to change the y lab
to that
and i'm actually gonna oh whoa
maybe i'll do that okay
and after that i'm gonna add a title to
it so i'll do a labs
title equals average
flavor flavor
profile
cool so what i also want to do is maybe
change those i might just uh
you know i might just do a core flip
let's see how that looks
you know what i kind of like that so i'm
gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna do that
and i'm gonna remove that so right now
we have
one uh one chart that we can use in
our in our dashboard so let's go on to
another one
so one thing i was thinking about is if
we go back
we could see like what's unique to each
country of origin
and if we look down where is it let's
see here
um when we see there's oh there's
different processing methods
um what else is there
there's different producers they're just
regions
uh what's here else
what what can we look at
and there's oh yeah there you go and
there's different varieties
so if we do this if we do a uh coffee
ratings select coffee
oops was it a country of
origin and a variety
we see there's a lot of different
varieties one thing i'm going to do is
i'm going to probably drop dnas
so i'll just say filter country
of origin is equal to ethiopia
and then we'll just select a variety
right and then what i'm going to do is
count the varieties
maybe do us and then we can just do a
mutate variety equals factor
reorder variety by n
and we can just throw that into a gt pi
right
a yes x equals variety actually we'll
see
um x equals n y equals variety
and maybe throw that into a gm column
right and that's a pretty good looking
chart we can just say
um we need excellent or was it y lab
and then plus uh labs title equals like
being
variety
right and then we can also throw a fill
equals variety
and that makes sense that's a good
good chart that's something that's
probably going to be what i think would
be kind of interesting to look at you
know if in case you want to look at
you know other african african um
coffee and see the varieties that they
have right ethiopian heirlooms
gesha other ethiopian uh yoga chef
your chef which is a very popular uh
coffee i never order it because it's
about like 18
a pound but i'm sure you guys might want
to try it
so once we have that i'm i'm curious
what else we can do
um one thing that i think would be
useful is if we have a table too so
a lot of dashboards have tables so let's
figure out like what would be
something that we would want to
summarize as a table right
and i think what we should do is
basically say like filter
um country of origin
is equal to ethiopia
and then what else do we want to do so
we want to select probably total cut
points
um probably the country of origin just
so when they filter it we can know what
it is
what else do we want
um
maybe maybe the region maybe the region
would be useful to have
right
yeah maybe the region
oh and also maybe i'll do a total cut
points and then we'll do
the uh where's the species too
the species of coffee
right so we have all that stuff and what
i'm actually going to do is i'm going to
do a like a group by
uh species and region
then do a top and of total cut points
n equals one ungroup
and then we'll just arrange by in
descending order total
cup points right so that's that's
that's pretty cool maybe i won't
man i don't know if i want to do region
because that that looks very
long
maybe we can also do a mutate for this
thing so like was it mutate
region equals scr was it
um was what is it
sdr
trunk trunk it
and then i'll do region
um just let me look up that's your trunk
trunk
okay yep yeah so sdr trunk will say
like eight and say
was it right
oh i thought do that
maybe i'll do a a 10
or a 12. right
so that would that's good additionally
what we can do is i can also do
um well in the cable what is it oh
i don't think i have it on my machine so
i'll install the
was it cable extra package
and kate what the cable package cable
package does is it basically makes nice
tables
um which is useful for you know doing
dashboard style tables so it's not just
a really gross looking you know output
which
so it doesn't look like say that
we can do a nicer html
um thing oops
library cable extra
you could throw that in right so it's a
little bit cleaner
this is just html on the um ethiopian
thing so
it's gonna look a little bit odd that's
fine
so now what i think interesting is
if we actually do some selections
of say if we want to select ethiopian
coffee i think the big idea behind this
is we need to
compare it to the other countries right
so what i think we're going to do is i'm
going to do a select
uh was it country
of origin and was it
aroma to um was it cupping
aroma to it's a year was it aura
copper points points
and what we'll do is we'll do a mutate
and we'll say um we'll just say
highlight or we'll say yeah highlight or
comparison
yeah i think highlight because this is
the thing that we really want to
highlight
equals if else country
of origin is equal to ethiopia
then uh highlight
and then no high white
rape we got that
yes okay
so another thing that we should do is we
should just say uh
um was it select now we don't really
need the country of origin
anymore and what i think would be
interesting to do basically is do like
a confidence interval of the differences
of it so kind of just run a t-test on
all these
um different type of factors i know that
there's probably like a violation of the
assumptions for the t-test
however i just want to grab the
confidence intervals and it's really not
for
a great statistical analysis it's just
this uh highlight
or the main differences between this
selected
uh origin of coffee and the others
so definitely not the the most uh
insane analysis but i think it'd be kind
of a useful analysis
especially for a cool little dashboard
so that's what we're going to do
value equals value and then minus
highlight
i think we also need the load in the
broom package so
broom
okay and this is what we're gonna do
we're gonna do a group by
key a do and then a t
test equals t test uh was it
value to highlight i think it might be
the other way around data equals dot
and then i'll do a tidy let's see what
that works
yep and then what we can do is a
was a nasty test
and we have our intervals so you have
our estimate of the difference and then
we have
the confidence uh well comments high and
that's what we can do
for the uh the constant rules for so we
can kind of like show them in a gigi
plot so was it gg plot a yes
x equals key y equals
estimate color equals key
plus gm um i think it's
the error bar or is it geom it's like
line range or is it point range
point range yep a yes and then y
min equals conf dot well y
max equals conf dot high
let's see how that works
cool we have that that's exactly what we
want
i'll do also a uh geom uh
a-line y-intercept equals zero
line type equals uh we'll say oops
dashed plus chord flip
plus theme
legend position equals none
cool um another thing that i might do is
be kind of cool to do some coloring on
it but just that i'm gonna do
yes i think we should do some coloring
so i think the big idea is
if these little intervals are
if both intervals are to the right or to
the left
of zero so if they're above or below
zero then
it means that they're different if
they're not then their means they're
probably the same
so how are we going to do that first i'm
going to
do a mutate and we'll say
difference d let's just say different
it's equal to
and when we're doing multiple kind of
like decisions
or multiple checks it's easier to see a
case statement so we'll say
um if conf dot low
is less than zero and conf dot
high is less than zero then it's
different if comp dot
low is greater than zero and conf dot
high is greater than 0 then it's
different
else what do you do true it's not
different
we'll just run this and then i'll say
the color will equal to difference
and i spelt difference wrong i try to do
different both different
and different differences okay cool and
we can see it here
it's working how we would like it okay
great
so i'll just say plus was it
xlab is done is not
yep so now i have that and then let's
just
add a title so we'll say oh uh was it
labs let's say
title is equal to how different
is
the origin to the rest
how different is the flavor
oh flavor oh wow why is my
flavor pro how different are the flavor
profiles
great grammar okay and then what i also
want to do
if you notice i want to i want to kind
of clean up those things
so what i'm going to do is what are we
going to do here okay and we'll do a
mutate key equals
sdr replace key
and then we'll scr to
title and i think that works
that works perfectly one other thing
that i might do is i think
it'd be kind of nice to reorder this so
i'll do a reorder
so i'll do ah
yeah i think i think we should reorder
it okay so i'll do with that too
so mutate key equals re
factor reor reorder
and then we'll reorder it by key and the
let's just say the estimate
there we go and actually
maybe we'll do maybe we'll do the
absolute estimate
no no we'll just we'll just do absolute
estimate that makes sense
it will do my assessment
cool so i think that's a this is a
good-looking chart
um let's go back and see if we need to
change anything
no i think that's it okay so i'm gonna
actually save this
i'm gonna call us tidy
tuesday coffee
ratings ratings okay
so i'm gonna put this back down in my um
uh my uh my markdown file i'm actually
gonna delete this little
object area even though it doesn't
really matter
and i'm going to do is open up a shiny
web app
what we're going to put this in is i'm
going to put it in my
tidy tuesday
tuesday and i'll call this um coffee
oh coffee what is called coffee i think
renames it a coffee app right okay it
doesn't
okay so what i'm also gonna go to is i'm
gonna go
to shiny dashboard and i'm just gonna
copy
their template for it because it is much
easier to do it like this like this
i also i'm probably gonna have to
install shiny dashboard so i'm gonna do
the first
install.packages shiny dashboard
okay so i'm gonna load this up wait for
it to install
nothing too crazy
i'm going to paste this in
cool paste it in
i always forget how they name the titles
okay it's just title great
so i'm going to say title equals
coffee dashboard
just run the app just to make sure it
works save it
pops out
and we have a coffee dashboard already
so
cool so one of the main things between
um uh r shiny
and just any type of shiny dashboard is
essentially it's just a bunch of inputs
and outputs
and inputs are the things that you're
trying to put into your output
so so inputs you want to think of it as
like filtering things so like
an input would be i want to filter by
ethiopia
okay so first i think the main the big
thing that we could do
right now is just do our outputs it kind
of sounds counterproductive
however since we already have all of our
charts that we want to put into it
we can kind of get away with it we can
just paste them in and then
start adding in the inputs later so
we're going to do that we're going to go
in tight reverse broom
i think we also do cable extra
and we'll just you know make sure those
are loading
okay so here's what we're gonna do
we're gonna go and grab our dash our
charts that we want to put into it we
only made four charts
so it's not going to be too hard to put
into it
okay and our charts are the things that
we want to show which would be our
outputs how we want to filter our chart
is how we're going to do it with our
inputs
so this is our flavor profile chart so
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
copy this
and i'm going to say output and you have
to
you know the dollar sign and we're going
to name this output and we're going to
say
coffee uh we'll say
coffee filet uh
flavor oh full flavor
and we'll say since there's a plot you
just do render
whatever it is and then
you throw in the the curly brackets so
you can do any data manipulation stuff
okay so that is our first plot
cool and now what we're going to do is
we're going to grab this plot
and this is called like bean variety so
we'll just say like
coffee variety or something like that so
output
coffee variety render plot
boom and that's our output right there
it's just that plot
nothing too crazy yet
and then now for this one this is
actually
a um a cable and what cable actually
does is it writes in html anyways
so you don't have to have to do any
rendering so you can just say output
say coffee we'll just say table and then
we'll say
function and throw that in
oops no function function
and throw that in because what these
things are doing so render plot
is just converting this ggpot object
into an html thing
so since cable already makes it into an
html thing
or an html object we can just do
function since we don't have to render
an html into an html object
i know this sounds a little confusing
but um it's just something that you kind
of get used to
and it's really not too not too
complicated you just have to
um learn how um each kind of plot is
named after for like the rendering
okay so now for our last plot on this
will be our coffee
like diff so render pot
and boom so now we have all of our plots
and that's basically it so that's
basically all of our server functions
we're done with it now we can just start
adding it to our dashboard
okay so in this case i'm going to say
fluid row
and fluid row because i want two rows
right
i want two rows of for the plots
you know it's gonna be a four by four
grid one two plots for each row
two plots for each column uh or tables
you know
so the first plot that i want to add on
to it is i want to
i think it'd be interesting to do bean
variety and maybe
um yeah i'll do bean variety
and uh
oh it's here bean variety bean variety
and average
flavor profile i actually might not do
the chord flip
wait
oh well actually yeah
yeah we'll we'll worry about that later
okay sorry about that
so so now they have a so basically said
that we want two rows
of uh of outputs and each output is
inside a box
and that's dependent that's because
we're using shiny dashboard
so we're gonna do a box and a box
right in our and our output will be a
um
will be a plot
coffee flavor let's see what that looks
like
oops
oh oops that's why i'm sorry
so you can't so we're going to first try
to do coffee flavors as we
we wait no it's not coffee flavor oh wow
whoa whoa
what am i doing here sorry sorry about
that um
we have to load our data so we're do
we're gonna
also load in the coffee ratings sorry
about that guys
and then um if
so we're gonna try to do just box you
know coffee flavor let's see what
happens if we do that
we run into an error because it's not
found because we actually have to
surround it next to a
plot output
and then we can do the coffee
like coffee flavor
flavor so that's what that does
and now we have our plot very nice
so now we can also do our next one so
we'll do a plot
output and what i say uh we wanted
the bean variety right so bean variety
um
and we'll call it we call that coffee
variety
yes so we call that
coffee variety and we'll just throw the
other one in too
so we'll do a plot output and we'll say
was it the coffee diff
coffee diff right
coffee diff
then we'll do another one and i think
this is a render
uh and i think we can actually just say
render u
i it's a uh
coffee
table
so let's see what that does
okay cool so this is the thing i think
actually i don't have to
do that i can just say coffee table
let's see we'll see if that works
oops maybe
what was it
render was it uh
maybe i'll do that
hmm just let me let me just google this
a little bit
just like render cable and are
shiny
function table output oh okay so it's
just table output
nothing too crazy
table output
i just dropped my mic
and we can see our table right here
so we're gonna have to do some very some
more things so was it cable
um cable extra and that's
um what is it
cable styling we do cable styling
we go to the cable package
you can see there's many options so you
do like um you do stripes
uh hover condensed stuff like that let's
look at it
so one thing i'm looking at is maybe we
don't want this to be super wide right
maybe we want to actually do something
change it a little bit
so what we can do is if we go here we
can say
um where is it
was it html only features and we can
actually do a scroll box so we can say
uh scroll oops
scroll box and we'll say what is it
hi is equal to 50 percent
or something like that let's see what
that does
or maybe we'll just do 200 200 px and
we'll say
width is equal to 200 200 px
i'm not gonna mess too much with the
table because it's not really important
um you can just kind of tweak the widths
and heights and you'll eventually get it
it's really dependent also on your how
you're viewing it and stuff like that
now
and the size of your your dashboard okay
so i definitely want to make my width a
little bit bigger
so i'll do my width to be what 500
px this is my last time running it and
then we'll start doing our inputs
okay so now i'm going to actually go on
to the inputs
so one thing we can do is we just do
select input and there's a ton of
different inputs you can do you have to
go on r shiny and kind of look it up
but all inputs have a id so we'll say
this
we'll save and i like to start call that
ids with a v
so v and we'll say um country
you know you give it a label and then
you give it the options
or the the choices and our choices
for what we want to do is coffee ratings
but specifically we're going to do is
select country
uh was it uh what's origin
i said
uh so what we want to do
is the user country of origin yep
so select country
of origin distinct
and we'll do a range by country
of origin and we'll do a drop
and n a okay
so we're gonna throw that in there as
our as our one input
because this is gonna be a simple
dashboard we only wanna filter by
country
of origin so we'll do that
and then we can run this app and see how
it looks
okay cool so we have that
and we can change it around like that um
one thing
actually i'm gonna do something very
quick i'm gonna change this to
i'm gonna say points
z oh i don't think you actually need to
do that so i'll just say
point and then we'll say
country is equal to that okay so now
that we have our input we can say
we have our select input which is the
countries
called v country what we can do
is now we can just put it into our
actual server function and say
since we want to filter it with our
given input which is our select input
called v country we'll say select uh
input v
country so any country of origin that is
equal to
our input input
variable v country and we can just go
through it
and change where we were filtering
already
um and that's it so i'm just going to do
that
find where i said ethiopia
and we can just run this app and call it
a day for this tire tuesday
so we can see that we're sucked in
brazil right now
what's going on here
so let me reload the app
okay so that's weird weird but okay so
we have brazil right now if
we change it to say ethiopia we can see
that the dashboard changes
right and that's basically the end of
the end of this
video i'm going to do just some basic uh
cleaning for this
i'm not sure why it's doing this so
maybe i have to do points
is equal to that and i'll say country
is equal to that let's just do one last
tweak and then i'll kind of
do some summary thoughts on on
dashboarding with
fox dashboard
very good okay
oh i bet i know why so i'll just do i'm
gonna
do that
one way so it's saying is oh we don't
have enough so what i like to do
if we don't have that uh with the top
end i'll just do a arrange
by uh
arrange by was it uh points
descending order in points and we'll
just slice
one let's see if that works
that's kind of how you get around the
top end problem
hopefully i won't eat my own words when
i do that let's see if it works
let's see what's going on here
oh that's why
there we go so i just i just was running
into an error
where it wasn't uh i i forgot that i
renamed
the com and it didn't specify in the
downstream pipeline
and there we go we have it it looks
fantastic
so just to collect my thoughts um it's
actually very simple to throw in
um like transition in our markdown
uh report into a dashboard and actually
think it provides a lot of utility
and although this uh video was pretty
slow it probably took a decent amount of
time
once you get the hang of it it is very
fast additionally what i recommend
is to just keep it simple so if you know
you're always gonna be making these like
four panel dashboards
you can save this as a template for
future dashboards
uh you don't really have to reinvent the
wheel um
finally i guess the main thing that you
have to remember
is that our shiny or any shiny dashboard
is about inputs and output outputs
where inputs are essentially your
filters and your outputs are anything
you're trying to see
um a problem with the outputs is that
there's different types of like
renderings
or like uh plot outputs so for example
um when i was doing the table output for
cable
um there's multiple ways to actually
render it um so that's called that's
just going to be a lot of trial and
error
but it's not too bad and hopefully i'll
see you guys next week and tidy on